president biden digging in his heels as
another democratic governor lets mass
mandates expire as covid cases plummet
in the u.s and across the pond the uk
completely dropping its restrictions fox
news contributor lara trump joins us now
great to see you as always my friend how
is joe biden this tone deaf when so many
of his fellow democrats are saying look
it's time to move on
well i guess it's a tough call as we
heard from joe biden there todd
look i have two young kids so this is
pretty clear to me this is called you
don't want to admit defeat i guess
that's the only conclusion so many of us
can draw at this point you look at the
science he just talked about the science
there the science has been very clear
that there's a negligible effect on
covet transmissions from masking we've
known that for quite some time it was
donald trump don't forget that said the
cure cannot be worse than the disease
itself he said that at the very
beginning of coven and yet here we are
in this space where the impact of
masking is actually so much worse than
the the current covet situation out
there you look at the impact of small
businesses so many aspects of our life
you take kids alone who are forced to
wear these masks still in school in so
many places we know they can't
concentrate
they get headaches from wearing these
masks all day young kids are having
trouble speaking because they can't see
the mouth of the teachers and adults
socially it's impacting kids negatively
for those reasons alone you ought to get
rid of the mass and then you look you
guys just said it so many democrat
governors across the country have gotten
rid of the mass mandates they're letting
them lapse at this point because they
got the polling numbers don't don't
forget that this has nothing to do with
what is good for the people they got the
polling and it turns out people don't
like being masked so the only conclusion
you can draw is that either the biden
administration doesn't want to admit
defeat or they don't want to give up
control at this point over people's
lives because they've had a lot of
control either way you can put it in
another category where all of joe
biden's decisions have gone the wrong
decision forward for america and then
speaking of uh won't accept defeat on
this a new fox news poll uh a 2020 if
the 2024 vote and election were today 36
percent would re-elect biden but 60 said
they'd vote for someone else so it
brings us to our next topic uh the
democrats are now somewhat praising
hillary clinton and kind of sneaking in
that she might
potentially run again how bad is this
for the democratic party that they're
trying to make her out to be the golden
girl here and how good could this
possibly be for the republicans and you
know laura in the same sense i mean is
hillary really going to step in and
solve this issue of inflation and the
border crisis
oh well it's a great question ashley i
think we'd all like to hear hillary's
thoughts on on those things but yeah her
name keeps coming up she will not go
away and you have to ask yourself why
are we still talking about hillary
clinton she lost to donald trump in 2016
and that absolutely embarrassing defeat
yet she is just around constantly and i
think you're right i think a lot of
people are assuming maybe she's the only
hope for the democrats at this point as
we head to 2024 you got 60 percent of
the country who want the current
president joe biden to take a cognitive
test that is really alarming on so many
levels kamala harris's poll numbers are
just about as low as you can go so
hillary ekes out
kamala harris just by a little bit but
hillary clinton is very unlikable again
she lost to donald trump in a recent
head-to-head matchup against donald
trump who so many people think and i
won't break news here today will be the
republican nominee
in 2024 she she performs performs very
poorly she did not win against donald
trump but look it does say ashley the
democrats are in a desperate situation
they've made all the wrong decisions
americans feel the negative impact of
their policies right now life feels a
lot harder for people since they have
the house the senate and the white house
and you know what they're in a little
bit of a pickle as they head to 24 maybe
they're banking on hillary again drag
her back up folks shake her off maybe
she'll be back again for 24. we'll see i
mean the cynic in me says hillary's the
source of all this drama all these leaks
all this new sort of press interest but
there's also the fact that democrats
have zero bench this is probably coming
from the dnc lara trump is coming from
florida we appreciate your time as
always have a great weekend enjoy the
big game hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade
i want you to do me a favor i want you
to click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page this is the only way that i
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now